I'm Asian I'm Asian I'm Asian I'm Asian
I'm Asian I'm Asian and I'm
white hi everyone I'm Leanne I'm fully
Chinese and I was born and raised in
Hong Kong a little fun fact about me and
cantones
is which is I did Chinese dance for 13
years hi my name is Caleb I'm
Korean AKA I'm
Korean by fact that was the fun fact K
his fun fact was that he was
Korean my name is Cammy I broke my
fourth finger at Chuck-E-Cheese so if I
ever get married it's going to be
crooked my future husband get it right
hi everybody my name is Kevin uh I am
Chinese American
[Music]
and I only started learning Chinese in
uh the summer After High School and I
spent the year in China and had just an
amazing amazing time and the more that I
learned the more that I wanted to learn
and so I ended up getting really good at
it I really don't like eating cilantro
which is which is the worst for if
you're Chinese like I mean everything
has got cilantro in it Kevin seems kind
of suspicious just the way he kind of
sounds bro sounded
white so um that means hi everyone my
name is Ryan and I really like eating
preserved egg and minced pork porridge
with dry instant noodle oh what's your
what's your eity oh I'm Chinese American
I forgot I am 100% Filipino speaking of
Filipino mauai I am Liara I am a proud
first I'm here to represent the
Philippines along with Cammy over there
to prove that we're really Asian uh hi
I'm Ana I'm South Asian I'm from India a
fun fact about
me I learned swimming when I was a kid
but then as I grew up I forgot how to
swim I have a question for everyone what
is the first thing you do when you enter
someone's household take period green
flag some people don't take off their
shoes in my household and I'm like I
don't know how it's just disgusting
that's a little rough oh also do you
guys have home clothes like oh
yeah home clothes yeah do you not change
into liketh my mom would always was
clothes she to shower before you get in
the bed oh yeah wait what is the the p
word that any Asian kid wants to hear
from their parents proudy I'm proud of
still waiting for that day to come y'all
been to
Kuman the ma oh my God you real
one oh Chinese School you guys go to
Chinese school I went to Chinese every
Saturday um what's your favorite subject
in school math biology okay hit me with
some like extracurriculars cuz I did
like tesan dance I did cheer gymnastics
I did fencing Chinese dance swimming
saxophone piano how do you got she's
literally
Barbie as a Filipina obviously I sing do
you tining too huh tining you don't
know what is that oh yes with the sticks
and you
like the
right
[Music]
Ryan shout out El Hamra but that's all I
heard a tie oh word and the tie is
between Ryan and Caleb oh ah damn so
going back to it so I'm Chinese so my
ancestor like ancestral heritage lies in
South China but my parents actually Comm
immigrated to the US from Vietnam I've
never had to prove how Asian I am
because I grew up from a very um
predominantly Asian community in the San
Gabriel Valley all right so I'm Korean
um I grew up in the bay uh there's a lot
of Asian people in the bay um Daily City
huge you know Filipino Community but I
just kind of grew up you know speaking
Korean
so
okay don't walk Ryan we'll get you I was
upset I have never had to prove that I
was Asian but I guess I'm not Asian
enough now let's get back to the video
you know I feel like Asian YouTube was a
huge thing for the Asian Community you
know different place oh yeah who who
yall watch Wong Fu right here guava
juice my fellow guav juice and you
remember Fun Brothers oh my gosh did you
remember Michelle Fawn makeup Community
Channel Community I was Jubilee oh yeah
Jubilee oh Jubilee when they used to
make short films when they subcribe okay
guys I want to know what is your
favorite part of your culture oh the
food so much I want to say food too
Indian food slaps and missing it so much
I think food is kind of obvious answer
but I think really just like you know
being proud of what China has been able
to build and become on the world stage
every time I go to China with my family
it's just beautiful like to see the
cities and how everything's developed my
personal favorite is honestly the people
they have instilled Hospitality I mean
every Filipina is a nurse I got to be
honest I'm not a nurse I'm sorry Papa I
was going to say I like Hong Kong
because of how multi like International
it is did you go to International School
in Hong Kong no I went to a fully local
like school sound really American I mean
it's something that I get on a
day-to-day basis my friends tell me I
sound American my white friends tell me
that I sound whiter than them and I'm
like do you have a least favorite thing
about your oh I mean I grew up in the
Korean Church a lot of Gossip happens
over there so there's always a little
thing about like the Korean church and
stuff piggybacking off of what they had
mentioned we call it mangis they're just
gossips like they speak behind your back
and a lot of times it will be to family
members so I think while we do have a
great heart sometimes we're not as kind
to each other my least favorite thing I
think um is colorism sometimes and the
beauty standard is you know a lighter
complexion is more beautiful more
gorgeous but I I love the skin that I'm
in I don't know if like in Korean or
Filipino culture it's the same but like
in Chinese culture people can be super
direct about your personal appearance oh
NE like you're fat now all a where you
get all those PES from I don't want to
get cancelled for saying this a lot of
it is is still like patriarchal and it's
so normalized like you know you see
someone walking by it's so okay to like
fat shame them or like like say oh
they're so dark why they here like that
happens a
lot I'm going go back to it I think
Kevin just sounds more
white Caleb from the very beginning I
was like I got to get him out he has to
leave ah
damn damn I I really wanted the money
gas is expensive in California so please
raise your hand if you want to continue
playing the
game so at this point I'm the only guy
in a group of girls so I felt like I was
in the hot seat and then I was thinking
maybe the only other person who was who
people could be suspicious of was Leanne
Leanne do you speak Mandarin I do speak
Mandarin oh no I'm not D at all because
I learned Mandarin at school it was like
a prerequisite so my mother tongue is
Cantonese I speak multiple languages
that's a part of the thing is like you
can always learn a
language of you know demand Chinese is a
language that a lot of people want to
learn or is in demand so I kind of had
an idea that it would be someone that
spoke Chinese stuff would be the mall
maybe it's Kevin what do you call your
parents like how do you refer to them
personal name but I call my mom Mimi and
my dad Bobby which that's my Chinese
name Mimi like kitty sometimes I'll call
him Chinese to be honest like a lot of
times in English my dad actually doesn't
speak great Chinese Mommy and then my
grandma is Mommy old I don't call him
like th that th no no no you're good
what did you think I said what oh I'm
sorry th is like short for that which me
I got to be honest I don't call my my
folk that I go mom mom mom mommy mom at
one point I was actually suspicious of
Camy I don't think she was that fluent
in her own language which I understand
it's like you don't have to be fluent in
your like native language so who do we
think is the hottest Asian like Asian
race I would say Chinese but you know
when I ever see Bollywood movies and
like the Indian actors and those I mean
some very goodlooking man and woman yeah
can I give a shout out to Dave Patel
Dave pel shout out but I also started
watching k
I was going to say Korean men are so
attractive Filipinos okay technically
speaking Miss Universe we have four
winners from the Philippines and I hope
to be Miss Universe one
[Music]
day Kevin we love you Kevin you're so
Chinese and I can feel it I can feel it
I can literally feel the entire China
behind you confidence please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game I knew for a fact that every woman
in this little box was Asian and I knew
that from my heart this is the
destination so end it here so we could
all
win all right this is going to be a
power round I voted not I believe I
voted not either there's still someone
just say who who it's EI the other two
like me and you Cammy but Cammy is like
she's FIP she's my sister she like feel
me or something said like you learned a
lot of different things in school as
humans I don't think it's possible to do
like 30,000 things just because like The
Stereotype you talking about me I didn't
do that at the same time that's all like
the extracurricular I accumulated over
the years like in fencing I did it from
um grade four to five and then saxophone
I've been doing since I was like grade
three to like last year also I feel like
Cy because you've been talking a lot
expressing your views on Philippines a
lot like you did your research on it
that she feels like my cousins so like
honestly I think it's lean I think I
don't I don't know what I need to do
like I am I'm fully
Asian it was another tiebreaker the
people who have the tiebreaker hammy and
Leanne here to State my I'm as I'm
Chinese at parties yes what is karaoke
song I have nothing when Houston I don't
really need to
look ask me any questions about my like
Hong Kong my culture my Heritage I feel
like those will be too rehearsed if I
ask I I have never had anybody question
my how like Asian I am like I I know
this is a bit traumatizing if this
becomes another tiebreaker we eliminate
two
[Music]
people two people eliminated oh I was
like girls like what I mean I was a
little offended because I never had to
prove that I was Asian um but it's all
fair game if the lights turn green that
means you have voted out the mole and
you win if the lights turn red that
means the mole is still in the box and
you lose you have won the game woohoo
wait can I give you high five yeah we
wait
oh my God Caleb I knew it oh sh oh
okay
yeah yeah it was kind of crazy because I
actually seen his videos before I think
it was a really good
surprise watches you I think I've seen
him yeah you might have yeah yeah it's
possible yeah my real name is Ari on
YouTube I go by shama which is my
Chinese name I lived in Beijing for a
year I learned you know mannering pretty
good I speak some canzanese too actually
you know I've been living in and around
Chinatown New York City for many years
my wife is also from China so um I'm a
full-time language learner I've studied
probably over 50 languages at this point
spend my days learning languages and
then going around speaking to people in
different languages and they get
surprised I'm so happy oh my God
I want to like pick it up we didn't get
to do a high five though do you want to
do a high five freeze no that wasn't
that we got to
jump
free